corona ist mit voller wucht zurück jeden
tag neue höchstwerte
was also tun das ist die große frage am
mittwoch gab es die krisensitzung in
berlin über acht stunden zäher
verhandlungen dann endlich weißer rauch
über dem kanzleramt
habemus corona konzept die neuen signale
sind allerdings verwirrend
frau merkel sagt so wir haben jetzt neue
maßnahmen aber ich sag es gleich ich
finde ich nicht gut die reichen im leben
nicht damit droht uns zitat der
kanzlerin unheil
aha und wenn ihr vielleicht einfach
weiter verhandelt bis euch maßnahmen
einfallen die reichen nur elf gedanke
wenn er angekündigt war doch ein ich
zitiere historischer gipfel ein
durchbruch eine hier
wir brauchen jetzt einen ruck das sollte
schon einen ruck geben da hoffe ich an
passiert dass wir morgen dann diesen
druck bekommen denn wenn es morgen
keinen druck gibt wenn es keinen druck
gibt dann rücken andere probleme näher
rucki zucki rückt näher
naja so richtig gerockt hat das nicht am
mittwoch immerhin jenseits von 50
infizierten pro 100000 einwohner kommt
die sperrstunde und private treffen
werden auf maximal zehn personen und
zwei haushalte beschränkt das ist dann
wohl die neue harte linie bei knallharte
linie wobei nrw hessen und
rheinland-pfalz haben schon dazu gesagt
dass mit den privaten treffen sei
erstmal nur eine empfehlung wegen
fehlender rechtlicher grundlage naja
abgesehen davon unsere ordnungsämter
müssen all die maßnahmen natürlich auch
irgendwie durchsetzen und das liegt bis
jetzt oft suboptimal wie hier in berlin
die verhängten bußgelder in der
gastronomie im bezirk mitte im juni 0
euro im juli 0 euro und im august auch 0
macht zusammen berlin halt sind ist
berlin
ja an solchen fronten oder in
unterbesetzten gesundheitsämtern wird
der krieg gegen das virus verloren wenn
wir nicht aufpassen
tatsächlich sollen ja sonst kein witz
private sicherheitsdienste die
ordnungsämter unterstützen so eine super
idee
am besten nimmt man direkt die hells
angels
die haben so eine natürliche autorität
sehen wir immer das positive wir haben
bald vielleicht fast einheitliche
maßnahmen für hot spots allerdings
leider nicht beim großen aufreger thema
dieses herbstes dem verbergen
sie wissen schon beherbergungs verbote
beherbergungs ob beherbergungs
beherbergungs boote beherbergungs
verbote beherbergungs verbot der werbung
beherbergungs verbot bewerbungs verbot
beherbergungs verbot bzw beherberge
beherbergung wo ist das problem
beherbergungs verbot so schöne übung
beim logopäden herbergsvater sepp
herberger beherbergt beharrlich
beherbergungs verbots verweigerer
vielen dank monatelang hat man gepredigt
macht bitte urlaub in deutschland um
dann quasi stunden vor den herbstferien
slug in keinem fall seid ihr bescheuert
urlaub in deutschland mecklenburg
vorpommern ist nur noch von 8 bis 22 uhr
geöffnet
das findet sogar karl lauterbach
überzogen stehen sich das bitte mal vor
geologen sagen innerdeutsche mobilität
spielt so gut wie keine rolle bei der
virus verbreitung es ist eine totale
phase der charlottenburger darf nach
amon der aus mitte nicht und der
charlottenburger darf auch nach am ohr
wenn er in mitte arbeitet sich den
ganzen tag dort aufhält abends ins
restaurant geht dann darf er immer noch
unter schleswig-holsteiner der in mitte
zwei tage vielleicht sei xing macht der
muss in schleswig holstein wieder
zurückfährt in quarantäne väter nach
charlottenburg nicht der
charlottenburger wiederum er kann nach
schleswig holstein ohne wenn er
zurückkehrt in quarantäne also dem kann
man ja kaum noch folgen
immerhin du hast es versucht du hast es
wirklich versucht in meine ich verstehe
ja dass die eher ländlichen regionen in
deutschland stolz sind auf ihre
niedrigen infektionszahlen so logisch
die haben ja sonst nix aber maßnahmen
müssen schon insgesamt nachvollziehbar
und sinnvoll sein und schrumpft die
akzeptanz der bürger rapide
mal ganz abgesehen vom todesstoß für die
tourismusbranche
da fehlt jetzt eigentlich nur noch
beherbergungs verbot the movie
sie wollten doch einfach nur urlaub an
der ostsee machen
doch die schlange vor dem chroma
testcenter war zu lang
die wahre geschichte einer westdeutschen
familie aus herne die zwei wochen rügen
gebucht hat wird ihre einreise genehmigt
werden
gejagt von den schergen des meck pomm
regimes kämpfen sie um ihre herbstferien
denn stornieren geht nicht mehr von den
machern von halbpension 2 nicht ohne
mein frühstücksbuffet mit dem wind nach
rügen jetzt im kino aber nicht mehr
lange in die kinos sind auch bald pleite
ja
jede wette am ende und es geht ja jetzt
schon los kassieren gerichte das ganze
beherbergungs dings komplett und der
schaden für die noch nicht insolventen
hoteliers landet beim steuerzahler
vorschlag könnten wir nicht mal ja eine
echte rechtsgrundlage für all die korona
maßnahmen schaffen und zwar nicht in
geselliger hinterzimmer wunde sondern
hier in diesem gebäude das wir genau
dafür mal angeschafft haben ja da und in
den landtagen muss all das endlich
wieder öffentlich debattiert werden
jetzt können wir aus der bude ja auch
spaß machen
ja meine wir reden hier von maßnahmen
die vielleicht sein müssen schon klar
aber die natürlich auch ganze branchen
über die klippe schicken können ich sage
nur sperrstunde ja nach 11 uhr auf stopp
das kann man machen aber auch da bleiben
natürlich schon noch fragen was ist in
dem bierglas drin
es ist stark bier alkoholfreies bier und
normales bier
man reagiere ich wo auf welches bierglas
kann also sein liebe berliner dass
demnächst der bürgermeister in die
kneipe kommt und von ihrem bier probiert
zur kontrolle erst dazu befugt er darf
das meine alkohol spielt natürlich eine
rolle bei unseren neuen infektionszahlen
trotzdem ist die sperrstunde sogar unter
virologen nicht unumstritten in england
hat sie die saufereien nachweis nicht
vor allem auf die straße verlagert man
kann ja theoretisch auch früher trinken
am führenden virologen jetzt
rausgefunden sperrstunde trifft halt
auch all die gastronomen mit
funktionierendem hygiene konzept heute
hat ein berliner verwaltungsgericht die
sperrstunde der erst mal direkt gekippt
für berlin selbst party und clubkultur
sollten wir nur ihren versuchen doch
zumindest sich der korona lage
anzupassen
der neueste trend sind virtuelle clubs
ist kein witz ein dj legt irgendwo auf
und die partypeople feiern bei sich zu
hause mit vr brille
nötig ist wenn man noch bei seinen
eltern wohnt die eigentlich tatort
gucken wollen
man muss sich was einfallen lassen
meine partys sind garantiert teil
unseres problems keine frage trotzdem
ärgerlich wie manche politiker die
jugend insgesamt als corona bösewicht
stigmatisieren gerade zu stigmatisieren
in wirklichkeit jetzt hier noch nicht um
jung gegen alt sondern um vernünftig
gegen kommt beides in allen
altersgruppen vor soweit ich weiß
deswegen würde ich den leicht pastoralen
maßregel ton langsamer so ein bisschen
runterfahren
ein besonderer appell geht heute an die
jungen leute es ist eine solidarische
pflicht auch der jungen nicht nur an
sich zu denken schreibt euch das auf
ihre kleinen ego bratzel
in vielen schulen sitzen die schüler
seit august den ganzen tag mit maske im
unterricht teilweise acht neun stunden
demnächst entdecken und fälle gewickelt
damit sie beim lüften keine
lungenentzündung kriegen hätten
erwachsene längst den betriebsrat
eingeschaltet und laschet ist kein
einzelfall
am mittwoch gab es einen ähnlich tanten
haften appell von angela merkel an die
jungen menschen
wir schalten wir live nach berlin dort
fährt birte schneider im auftrag des
kanzleramts im sogenannten no fun mobil
durch die hauptstadt um um was zu machen
um jede form jugendlicher lebensfreude
im keim zu ersticken es geht leider
nicht anders
junge menschen schwimmen geradezu in
hormonen die ihre kleinen gehirne
aufweichen alles was die wollen ist
feiern laufen oder sich aneinander
reiben rubbeln schwitzend wie die tiere
ekelhaft
abmarsch nach hause freundchen ich hab
dich im auge so ist gut so ins gut heute
breit große männliche teenager allein
schon wie die riechen ja ich behaupte
gerade die jungen sind im moment
gekniffen es gibt immer weniger
ausbildungsplätze und
überbrückungshilfen für studierende sind
september ausgelaufen obwohl corona
wieder fahrt aufnimmt muss man da
ausgerechnet auf die so drauf haut muss
man es ist die einzige sprache die diese
halbstarken verstehen
mit ihrem unverantwortlichen bedürfnis
ständig gleichaltrige zu treffen bei
illegalen race oder wie das heißt wir
haben die kontrolle verloren
berlin ist inzwischen eine einzige orgie
hier mit versteckter kamera gedrehten
aufnahmen aus einem club in mitte die
schweinerei an das eskalierte und von
diesen partys kommen die dann alle
schwanger nach hause und stecken ihre
oma mit corona an die zahl der
psychischen erkrankungen bei jungen
menschen nimmt sprunghaft zu es gibt
immer mehr häusliche gewalt natürlich
haben die das bedürfnis auch mal
rauszukommen ja geht aber nicht erwirken
gebt nicht ganz ehrlich für mich stehen
junge leute mit fire bedürfnis moralisch
auf einer stufe mit osama bin laden und
da bin ich nicht alleine die
ordnungsämter die polizei aber auch die
bundespolizei wenn man das also mit
vereinten kräften also kontrolliert und
das sind ja ganz bestimmte plätze immer
wo sich die gefährde sammeln er fährt
endlich sagt es mal einer
ob ich jetzt mit 20 anderen idioten beim
späti dosen bier saufen oder mir einen
sprengstoffgürtel um schnelle wo ist der
unterschied noch mal ohne corona regeln
feiern ist sicher ein problem aber junge
leute passion garantiert nicht die
lösung jede erwachsenen generation
schimpft immer auf die jugend ja kann
sein herr welke
aber die heutige jugend ist halt auch
besonders widerlich mit ihren ärgerlich
eng sitzenden hosen und dem ganzen
social media gewöhnst dich jetzt mit
podcast schnauder diese wichtigtuer
brauchen die harte hand hatte bist du
das mama was machst du hier klickst du
wieder mit fremden männern flittchen du
ich kann das erklären dass das ist ein
interview aber nicht sind sehr
enttäuscht
mama warte wirte schneider
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
ersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und liegt - wollt dann abonniert jetzt
den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal der stelle
[Musik]